The U.S. President Joe Biden has welcomed the arrest warrant...
...issued against Vladimir Putin by the International Criminal Court on Friday.
Russia's president is accused of war crimes...
...focusing on the forced deportation of Ukrainian children to Russia.
It's the first time the court has ordered the arrest...
...of a prominent serving political leader.
Ukraine's President Volodymyr Zelensky has hailed the decision as historic.
Moscow, they dismissed the announcement as outrageous...
...saying it doesn't recognize the jurisdiction of the court.
Here is BBC's Helena Wilkinson.
It's a war that he ordered.
A war that brought death and devastation.
A war that sent millions fleeing for their lives.
But it's one that has now left President Putin accused of war crimes...
...by an international court and even more isolated on the world stage.
The judges have reviewed the information and evidence submitted by the prosecutor...
...and determined that there are credible allegations...
...against these persons for the alleged crimes.
The International Criminal Court based in the Hague, alleges the Russian leader...
...and another official are individually responsible...
...for the war crime of unlawfully deporting children from Ukraine to Russia.
This was the reaction from President Biden to the ICC's move.
Well I think it's justified,...
...but the question is, it is not recognized internationally by us either.
But I think it makes a very strong point.
He's clearly committed war crimes.